Yeah,
support for big thing comes from
Microsoft delivering people ready
enterprise solutions designed to help
companies do more with less details at
Microsoft.com/people ready.
It's actually more possible to move
market share than it might be in a
normal environment and so being able to
have better awareness and being able to
more quickly respond competitively is of
more importance.
Realtime monitoring is a process by
which companies are building business
intelligence to understand in the way
that a national intelligence agency
would what is actually going on in the
ground on the ground in different parts
of the world,
in different parts of their business
that allows them to more quickly respond
to changes in the external economic
environment,
to competitive moves,
to changes in the financial markets,
to changes in prices and reactions of
different moves that they're making so
that they can have an awareness of how
each of those changes may influence what
their business response should be and
more quickly adapt to them.
Even before the crisis.
The,
the Internet and other related
communications and information
technologies enabled a level of
transparency inside of institutions.
Not just businesses,
but government and social sector
institutions that was not possible for
before,
whether it's yelp for restaurants,
whether it's youtube for a social
movements,
whether it's the ability to create a,
a movement on the Internet that creates
a new president.
Those are environments that would not
have been possible without the
ubiquitous the capability and the low
cost of technology and we've not yet
seen what that means for how companies
and large organizations actually operate
in that new environment.
It's going to force a level of
transparency.
It's going to force a level of ability
to respond quickly to things that is
going to challenge many traditionally
organized institutions.
Uh,
I think in the intermediate term that's
actually going to be good.
It creates a kind of competitive
pressure,
a kind of necessity to deliver in the
light of day.
That in general will be good.
It will particularly be challenging,
but in some ways will be very good for
the most opaque institutions,
particularly in the government.
Creating visibility into how money is
spent.
Creating visibility into what the real
returns on investment are.
Creating visibility into the actual
activities that occur.
And how well they're done or not
creating visibility into how customers
and tax payers and employees think about
institutions is challenging,
but it forces institutions to be better
and that's good for the economy.
It requires that that technology be
thoughtfully invested against processes
and activities that actually make a
difference for the organization and that
you adapt how you do business to reflect
that technology.
I think that's going to be true in the
next generation of web to Datto
technologies as well.
They can be important enablers of
allowing particularly complex
transactions and interactions between
individuals and groups within a company
and between organizations to happen much
more effectively,
but they need to be done in a way which
are effectively implemented and
processes that are changed to take
advantage of that.
I personally find that quite exciting
and the opportunities for knowledge
sharing for real collaboration,
for opening up ways to interact with
people halfway across the globe in a
realtime way interactively is just quite
exciting.
And for someone who spent half their
life on an airplane,
being able to do that in video
conference rather than getting on an
airplane for a one hour meeting,
I find quite compelling as well.
I think the availability of some
technologies that allow for virtual
interaction,
whether it's really high quality video
conference or a web presence,
don't diminish the need for personal
interaction.
They just changed the nature of it.
And what it means is that you use the
time when you're together for the kinds
of social interactions and getting to
know people and really creating trust
and the relationships that then enable
you to operate,
to operate effectively,
virtually going forward.
Um,
it,
it doesn't diminish the importance of
being together.
It just changes the purpose of that and
allows you to be more effectively using
your time in different ways.
Given the availability of personal
interaction and technology intermediated
interactions and other settings.
Support for big thing comes from
Microsoft delivering people ready
enterprise solutions designed to help
companies do more with less details at
Microsoft.com/people ready.